This wasn't the easiest question,
because even though there was some hint that you had to use trigonometry,
it might not have been completely clear what triangle we're talking about.
This is the triangle I was looking at, this one in purple.
And here, it turns out the side opposite alpha is the width of the well,
which is 1 meter, and the side adjacent to alpha is the depth of the well, which is 40 meters.
So once again, as often happens in nature,
we were able to find a right triangle even though it wasn't totally obvious
at the start of the problem that it existed.
Okay, so we have a right triangle.
I know the opposite and the adjacent, which means I'm going to use tangent,
and I'm going to say the tangent of alpha is equal to 1/40.
Now I want to know what's alpha.
To figure this out, I'm going to type into Google arctan (1/40) in degrees.
And the answer I get is 1.4 degrees.
So this points to some error in the measurement.
It looks like we could have been off by as much as 1.4 degrees in either direction.
The sun's ray could have been coming like this, or it could have come like that.
That's certainly an appreciable error since the angle we had been dealing with before
was only 7.2 degrees.
But how does this error in angle correspond to an error in calculated circumference?